was a different kind of a night it was a
crazy kind of night i've had trouble
reminding myself what day it is today
because these tuesday night games right
are so rare and i feel like there should
be a game tonight because there's one
tomorrow night there were two monday
there was one last night let's just go
ahead and play a game every night of the
week except friday and saturday which
legally the nfl can't do but let's play
them and last night's game was was
you know it it
34-17 suggests it was more of a blowout
than it was it was in doubt for a while
the first half was exciting right it was
almost a hail mary a hail cd
where the the i i i don't know how many
times i can recall a hail mary where the
ball actually goes through the hands of
the receiver and he has a clear shot at
catching it so it was an exciting game
it was fun to watch and you know these
teams play each other once every four
years it's neat to see them on the field
together and i i like tuesday night
football i do too i mean listen i'm
enjoying it i i you know it gives us
something to talk about but you're right
it's just great to okay the day of work
is done whatever eat some dinner and now
you got something to look forward to at
night i mean it really is it's great to
sit there on the couch and watch a real
football game and like we always talk
about to focus on one game i think
that's the best thing about it game had
a little bit of everything though it did
i mean you're right there was drama
early on baltimore kind of looked like
they were asleep at the wheel or weren't
playing really good football you know
early whether that's the lamar jackson
you know interception
justin tuck uh tucker misses the the
field goal you never see that that was
like the total kibosh
jinx by joe buck and troy aiken to talk
about that much that was unreal how that
unfolded it's almost like they were
doing it to see if it worked right they
were like waving
does this wand work let's try to wave
this wand in the direction of justin
tucker to see if it works and it worked
it i mean it was great i mean the way
joe buck did it too i said i'm going to
be confident and he's going to hit 71.
we're not going to jinx him here i mean
it's just amazing how that happens but
uh it was there to be had a little bit
early on with dallas to go well they
could take control of this game
and put baltimore down by double digits
or put them in some tough spots but that
never really came about and lamar
jackson that offense kind of found their
way and then you know dallas stinkiness
on defense finally started to show
itself on play after play after play and
we see their issues there so it was a
good night by baltimore
i will say it wasn't perfect and i also
will say the defensive performance by
baltimore was a little concerning so
those are my little takes of the night
mike uh more than anything as far as the
game is concerned
there was a moment fairly early on that
reminded me of the seahawks game from a
year ago when the ravens first really
hit the radar screen as an elite team
when lamar jackson insisted on going
forward on fourth down and you know this
wasn't mentioned in real time during the
broadcast and i know that they are
processing a lot and they don't see what
we're seeing they're initially watching
the field
but
you could see lamar jackson on fourth
and two yeah that play that resulted in
the 37-yard touchdown pushing right get
out of here yeah right we're going for
it
and and that was like the moment that he
took it all on his back and he exploded
down the middle of the field and they
showed on the replay there was a giant
hole in the middle of the defense where
there was no one there to even try to
catch him not that anyone on that field
could have caught him but that was the
moment where
the rest of it just felt like details
even though again it still was in doubt
it still was close they still could have
blown it
but with that kind of
of just explosion from lamar jackson you
felt like if they needed something like
that later in the game they'd get it
again they really didn't need something
like like that later in the game no they
did it but that was our first like oh
wait okay
they are gonna they are gonna gash them
in the run game they are gonna make big
plays because up to that point they're a
little scared you're looking like oh man
baltimore doesn't look like they got it
all the way here what's going on uh but
great leadership by him you know again
having confidence in myself and then jim
i you know i give john harbaugh a lot of
credit you know he he does listen to his
players in these type of situations and
dallas just outmanned up front not big
enough and then leighton van der esh
who's really responsible for that
backside gap he was in a tough spot
there's a lot of movement going on and
he doesn't make the play and once lamar
jackson gets a step on you it's over
but even with that mike you know they
score the touchdown and it does it makes
you feel good then
the kick return happens for dallas and
they're down there close again and
you're going holy cow i mean what what
is going on here but then the game
settled in and baltimore clearly showed
that they were the better football team
the the
animation from uh next gen stats is is
impressive because
it it's as efficient as it can be the
closest distance between two points is a
straight line almost virtually literally
a straight line down the field for lamar
jackson but that's what happens when you
have that kind of burst acceleration and
speed you don't have to make any moves
and and you look at how everyone was
clustered up the line of scrimmage yeah
once you get past that first level
you're gone that's it no one has a
chance and there goes lamar jackson
shireen williams had been saying
with exaggeration that the ravens would
put up 300 rushing yards against the
cowboys and her exaggeration was almost
yeah right around 294. we thought 265 a
few weeks ago against the steelers was a
lot 294 against the dallas cowboys they
just couldn't stop jk dobbins lamar
jackson and gus edwards just like it was
against the steelers and and as this
team gets back to full strength his team
will be dangerous down the stretch and
what a monday night game it sets up to
be when the ravens go to play the
cleveland browns the ravens won 38-6 in
week one the browns got their signature
victory over the titans on sunday wow
and the browns got two extra days to get
ready for this one it's another six day
turnaround for the ravens as they ease
back into a normal schedule after their
covet 19 debacle and the browns have an
extra day because they played on sunday
anyway so two net extra days for
cleveland they're gonna need them if
this ravens team continues to hold it
together the way they did last night
yeah well they're gonna need them but
baltimore is gonna need practice too too
because that you know that game did not
make me feel like you know like i said
earlier confident warm and cozy about
baltimore hey yeah that run game we know
it it's an issue and when they do have
the three-headed monster at running back
i mean gus edwards ingram looks like
he's getting closer to being like
totally a hundred percent himself uh and
then jk dobbins man they got a little of
everything to offer for or offered to
you as far as the defense the
sledgehammer and gus edwards you know jk
dobbins on the edge running and his
speed and then ingram has a little bit
of both there more of the sledgehammer
cleveland though
you know they're going to be able to run
the ball on baltimore too i mean again
we've seen teams do that to baltimore
that's kind of the the bad thing about
them right now or at least the thing i'm
concerned about
and you know again i know they've gone
through a lot and haven't had everybody
healthy and there and they're even
banged up to this point still which i do
think affects their defense some
injuries in the secondary they're not
totally healthy up front that takes away
winks martindale's ability to do a lot
of creative fronts and things like that
when he's not comf comfortable with what
he's got in the coverage in the back end
so i think that's hamstrung them a
little bit but still
i expect that to be a very close
football game with the way cleveland's
playing right now and baltimore being
kind of up and down i mean i think it's
there to be had the browns could
establish themselves as a as one of the
new kings of the afc north
let's put a pin in that moment that
lamar jackson reminded us all that he's
still lamar jackson here he is after the
game talking about that moment on fourth
and two
i ain't gonna lie to you i wasn't even
thinking about it would be a fourth down
after the play got called you know i'm
just like we just gotta keep it going
like convert
but um yeah you know we did a great job
you know probably today i think we got
stopped on the job before that so we had
to go put points on
on the board you know we were driving
the ball downfield uh defense plan you
know lights out like always we just had
to do we had to do and coach called that
play the line did great i just had to
finish it off
and he did finish off and between the
browns and the ravens the cowboys have
given up over 600 rushing yards in two
games this year
cleveland had 307 the ravens had 294
unbelievable for them unbelievably bad
for the cowboys and you really do have
to wonder they're not three and nine we
have a little clip of ezekiel elliott
post game where he
sounds kind of strangely optimistic
you're three and nine i understand the
first place in the division is five and
seven but three and nine their best case
scenario is seven and nine what a
horrible season for the dallas cowboys
and i know it went off the rails when
dak prescott got injured but there was
so much hype about how they went out and
got andy dalton they had the foresight
to have a veteran quarterback look this
has just been bad and the defense has
been abysmal all year long that
cleveland game was before dak prescott
got injured the defense is horrendous
they got a lot of work to do in the off
season by way of getting players who can
run what mike nolan wants to do or
getting rid of mike nolan all due
respect and hiring someone who'll work
better with the players they have yeah
that i mean that's it it's one of those
two options but i mean it's amazing that
it ever got to that point i mean we
discussed this a lot earlier in the year
when dallas was a team we talked about
more but yeah i mean it's unbelievable
you know two things i think that's worth
mentioning there that you brought up you
know first off
there's three wins it's only one win
since dak prescott's been out only one
win i do think like i mean that
there's there's enough talent on this
team to
make things a little bit more
salvageable maybe win more games i i
will say that on the offensive side of
the ball it's been disappointing that
performance just lack of explosiveness
still with those weapons and andy dalton
like you're saying but the defense is
just atrocious that's why you couldn't
pick them in the game last night by any
sense of the imagination because
it doesn't even look right their
defensive line they don't even look like
a big time nfl you know front four or
anything like that and there's just so
many plays where they're asking guys who
have no business playing two gap defense
right mike can we talk about two gaps
are made for the giants of football that
can hold an offensive lineman up and
then sit there and disengage no matter
which way the ball goes you know they
don't have those guys and against the
baltimore ravens them trying to do that
good night and that's why you saw some
plays for baltimore where nobody's
touched until they were 15 or 20 yards
down the field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports